So I have a little bone to pick with Walmart.
I just went in there, and,
you know, in the front section, there's, like, a seasonal section.
They switch it up.
I saw the workers,
they were getting rid of the summer stuff,
the inflatables,
the life vest,
the barbecue stuff,
and they were putting up,
there was already a whole aisle of it.
A back to school stuff,
the notebooks,
the backpacks.
To any other moms or parents get, like,
irrationally upset by seeing back to school stuff.
It makes me so sad and, like, mad.
I'm like, just let us have summer.
Let our kids have summertime. Around here,
the kids got out of school last week,
and we're already talking about going back.
No, no,
let us have summertime, please.
Like, I don't know what it is.
As a kid and as, like,
a teenager, I hated it because I didn't wanna have to go back to school.
And then now as a parent,
like, I hate it even more.
I'm like, oh, no,
just let the kids be home and have fun and be kids.
I, I don't know.
It just, like,
I hate that so much.
Boo, boo! Thumbs down.